I'd biessed my way into jobs that I
didn't have the experience to do and
pulled it off but I had to believe in
myself to BS my way into a job there's
no place for patience in business you
know patience in life means things
happen slower than they could the last
thing you want to do is open the bar cos
you're like the drink that's like that's
like somebody into drugs who becomes a
pharmacist I mean next
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from bar rescue TV
host and world-renowned bar expert Jon
Taffer and my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one that you guys like the best
and as always guys if you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
you wake up in the morning you're
failing so you blame the president you
blame Congress you blame Greece blame
the euro
I mean you construction in the street
it's a mayor
oh it's did it and you wake up in the
morning and you look in the mirror and
you're not failing because it's the
other guy's fault which the economy's
fault but if you looked in a mirror and
said I'm failing because of me you
wouldn't like it and you change that and
I believe the common denominator of
failure in any business is excuses as
long as you wake up and blame poor sales
on the economy or an environment then
you have no motivation to make it better
because it's not your fault but in the
worst economic environment for five
years in this country the ago.the in
this country that we've seen in our
lifetimes do people making a lot of
money weren't there in the height of
that recession or people selling
advertising people opening restaurants
people building businesses somebody's
making money so the excuse is bull it's
bull so wake up in the morning and own
your failure look in the mirror and say
I'm failing because of me and you won't
like it
and then you'll change it but as long as
you don't put it on you you have no
motivation to change it so in short if
you own your failure you own your
success if you don't own your failure
you'll never dig out and I find that in
any business always the common
denominator of failure personally is
excuses you don't want to be a failure
do you don't want to look inherent and
experience that if you can't blame
anybody but yourself you're going to
change you're going to fight it out
that's the deal
IBS my way into jobs that I didn't have
the experience to do and pulled it off
but I had to believe in myself to BS my
way into a job and you were younger you
didn't have to produce or experience you
know but I but I always have the
confidence like I can do it I'll figure
it out exactly right and I knew I could
figure it out too when that gave me the
confidence to show up at the interview
and convince that guy to hire me because
I was convinced myself that I could do
it and that comes across let me
introduce you to the concept of success
then Franklin was a pretty smart guy and
I want to start with a quote by him
if you do tomorrow what you did today
you will get tomorrow what you got today
you want to know what that means
the average American makes between three
and five percent more each year that's
the deal and in today's economy I'm not
sure we're going to make the three to
four to five percent next year as
employees so it takes you 20 years to
double your income in America is an
average person that's the mediocrity
that we're stuck in in life and then you
meet people who have the uncanny ability
to double their income in a year to get
promoted five times in a year the ones
that beat the system the ones that
conquer it you've all seen them haven't
you
the difference between them and the ones
that don't do that is that they wake up
in the morning and they think
differently they understand that if I do
tomorrow what I did today
I'm going to get tomorrow what I got
today you want a bigger car how about a
nice house in Tahiti sure would you love
a nice house in the hills we all want
better things don't we we all want more
friends more stuff more money more
security more travel more enjoyment if
you do the same thing tomorrow that you
did today you're stuck stuck and it
doesn't change and it grows a little at
a time and you get a taste of success
but it's never fast enough it never
excites you and when it does it's a good
month or a good two months or a good
three months but it doesn't provide a
trajectory that creates success so the
first thing I want you to think about
today as I want you to wake up tomorrow
and do something different and
understand if you do the same damn thing
you're stuck just because you did it a
certain way yesterday there's no reason
to do it that way today I want it to hit
hard that's not what drives success you
do you do and you do when you go back
tomorrow you'll need to start counting
guests or you won't you leave a look at
your marketing budget and split it up to
new frequency or expenditure or you
won't you either look at your staff and
get rid of the dead weight that you know
is costing your money or you won't and
you'll look at your bar programs and
what you
or you won't and every one of you wrote
the word
action down at least a few times correct
do it do it
I'm just not patient there's no place
for patients in business you know
patients in life means things happen
slower than they could so if you're
going to be on this planet for 70 years
and things happen slower than they
should at the end of 70 years you're
going to have less aren't you less
experiences less time less money less of
everything so let's all hurry up man and
get more out of life that's my view so
patience is not am I crazy if you think
your life is complete then I suggest
that you're an ass because tomorrow
always has a great opportunity in it
your life is not complete until you
close your eyes so when you say somebody
who's in a job they hate we'd love to be
able to do this my comment is why how
are you want a job you hate bunch of the
courage to leave it so you're in a job
you hate you're doing nothing to change
it but you'd like better so tonight oh
did I do that I have mouths to feed
sometimes I get it but what were the
things about you not saying what we can
say even listen we'd have to go over
those specific cases I think it really
get them to each person to break them
what do you think that were the things
about you one of it is you always had
your eyes open to tomorrow and new
opportunities more some of the other
things as part of your personality for
because I there aren't many people like
you but I've seen and I'm studying more
and more people we're amazing things are
happening at 55 and 60 and putting them
on life journey that they never thought
they were going to have and I'm and I'm
seeing that you guys have a lot of the
similar attributes but what do you think
what was it about you John courage
courage now the first time I went and
shot a pilot for bar rescue is really
hard you think it's easy to scream at
people and national television to insult
people on national television to call
you a jerk challenge your marriage
channel during a challenger integrity
challenge your professionalism that's
hard that's not who I am I don't wake up
and embarrass people in front of their
friends
in front of their family bar rescues the
hardest work I have ever done the
courage that it takes me to go out there
and do these things when I was in my own
20s I was managing expenses and managing
marketing budgets and faced a lot of the
problems that you did my labor cost was
too high so shaving hours my marketing
expense is too high some shaving times I
can't give stuff away I have less
dollars for entertainment suddenly my
rent is expensive occupancy cost is
expensive my taxes are expensive and I'm
just focused on the fact that everything
is expensive then somebody came into my
business and taught me how to do a
promotion and literally a month later my
revenues went up 30% in a month when I
looked at my pl I didn't have a labor
cause the problem the numbers worked
suddenly I had a few dollars for
marketing I could actually buy some
stuff I had money for new paint on the
walls and I realized that day you don't
have expense problems in any business
all we have are revenue problems revenue
is the cure-all
that's the aspirin you take every night
to feel better in the morning is revenue
revenue revenue you got to wake up in
the morning and drive revenue which
means you got to have the promotion's
the ideas the energy to elevate a
business you got to be a Rainmaker in
business or you're never going to get
anyone wet and when they don't get wet
they dry up and go away and it's that
wetness of the Rainmaker that filters
down and trickles to everybody success
you have to drive the energy of revenue
to be successful and when you do you'll
have no expense problems anybody see the
Murphy's episode of Bar rescue the two
frat brothers opened the bar the last
thing you want to do is open a bar cause
you're like the drink that's like that's
like somebody into drugs who becomes a
pharmacist I mean that's just
makes no sense at all you got to do it
for the right reasons you got to do
because you love the business if you
love the social aspect of it you'll
never do your financials you'll just
hang with people all day long if you
love the drinking that's even worse you
got to love the business it's a tough
business and we were talking before we
started you know in a clothing store
business you buy shirts you mark them up
60 70 percent if you got 10 shirts on
the Shelf you go home that night you
come back in the morning you still got
10 shirts in the shelf not the bar
business Barbara's you got to manage
every minute right product is exposed
liabilities are exposed to tough
business honestly if I had to do it over
again I'm not sure I would be in this
business to be honest with you you know
when I look at all the work that I did
over the years I could have applied
those efforts to to bigger things rather
than smaller barns and I was involved in
rainforest cafe for example that went
public and that was big dollars don't
get me wrong I don't regret being in a
bar business but when I look at my life
all the nights that I worked all those
evenings days 20-hour days I look back
and say gee well that would have been a
lawyer not maybe not a wire but whatever
there are lifestyles that are easier is
my point so you got to love the business
and be passionate about it to make it
through those late nights and those
warnings
how did dear friend who's who works for
a large company and he wants to open a
franchise advise franchise of sandwich
stores I won't say which brand ok wants
to buy a little territory so he meets
with Mesa Johnny needs to advise do I
leave my long-standing job and benefits
and do this or do I'm it so why can't
you have your cake and eat it too right
why can't you bring in a partner why
can't you bring in somebody to do it
there's ways to get there it doesn't
have to be absolute so if somebody wants
to create a second career create new
opportunities in their life
figure out a way to do it without
risking what you have right and if you
want it enough you'll figure now
everything that we do is reactive
management if you can make your bosses
react the way you want them to
you're going to get a promotion argent
I'm going to get that job you want how
do you get them to react to you in a way
that gets you promoted when you figure
that out you'll get promoted
that's reaction analysis it's
understanding that those reactions that
happen around you drive your future more
than you do the only final advice I
would give you is I've lived a very
unconventional life and it's because I
live my dream everyday dreams are
inspiring work is not find the dream
whether it's that client you can't get
right that you've been fighting for for
six months you got to have dreams dreams
make this world go on it built our whole
country and when we get in a rut as
human beings is when we lose touch with
our dreams we lose the ability to fight
for those dreams so don't be an employee
of Google live your dreams at Google
find a way to you know match your dreams
with the goals of your company in your
own work because there's nothing worse
than mechanical employees that lost
touch with their dream and you know the
worst thing in the world is when you see
somebody who lost touch with their
dreams
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because shredder Steve
asked me to so if there's someone you'd
like me to cover in the next top ten
please check out the link in the
description so you can cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Tanya Jackson Tanya thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book gear
one word and posting that awesome
picture on Twitter I really really
appreciate it and I hope you're enjoying
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
much love I'll see
[Music]
I Drive quality as a leader my systems
maintain quality now with regard to new
projects to me every new project is a
ball and I have to move that ball every
day so I know for example that I have
four balls on my best they might be five
pads let's say five balls on my desk
they might be five different pads five
different books five different projects
every day I'm going to move those five
balls that's the way I live my life and
I can't go to sleep at night if I don't
move every one of those five balls every
day sometimes I have three balls
sometimes I have seven balls but the
amount of balls that I accept and put on
my desk every one of them is going to
move forward every day and I become
relentless so I've learned to live my
life based upon the progress I make on a
daily basis and I believe that business
is defined by what we do every day every
single day and business is defined by
the days that we have so if you move
those five balls every day you can't
help but be successful you will achieve
it but you'll achieve it on a daily
basis